[Music]
banderas thapa Son n Crown Johnny Eh lie good
luck guys 2 Stray
Ayukai Sogu
[Applause]
That child 1 ef Sam Super Mario Bad Spare
Kamarnets dalf Service Palmer Leespan 2
Another Border One Two ex anasui s Touring Palm  all this
pain festive sos order to do as ice xi
deep spomerless good
[applause]
sasami sapere special asaden usb car see
who do for
rre -5 super well lex menon dc to talk about
love us news venture
ep force to  do do serve forever Lady Erie
Scape for ms ime
[Applause]
Ta Wo Germany 0 I'm hungry be nice xe No. 4 chubby ror jere arel Force 4 Scarred we are Wow come
to do
Hi Thank you very much  I'm glad
you did it, but it's
ponomusic to do, but that German property species
is asamas fine kara
ras fine john lee
That country that is starting after all is a donation It's
exciting and fun-
hos 5  Size to do Fine sr fan
ai I'm very happy to see everyone at that venue in the water.
I think that this time Mario was made with our
team
thinking about making it a
travel-
themed game.  I hope you can enjoy encountering and experiencing things that have never happened at Mario 2 o'clock
voodoo
Buber cards but a polymer
continuous take that cappy has the ability to capture money.  At first, it gives Mario various skills by attacking enemies in the distance,
getting items, and
throwing them.
you do pt rosana serebu Dou
That's right
gx
Which one is boo boo fashion f 4 fb degree g Watched
Maria's other theme this time is the theme of surprise
, running around the city of kicking at that distance  I want to surprise everyone.
I'll introduce you to
re sure brother can do i Hengband is a revolver, but
I'm still looking forward to the kingdom theme here
.
Charging ces ev  Spanish Army Shopping Hyper soad f 4
a to do Lone Star Style p 2
This week I tried various things for those who have never eaten before when I came to Germany for the first time
this week in germany Affi people join join watch
face line reg  4
My favorite is
Tana Zhu Tachi
s 3 singer tours
.
Well, that Mario can also
fly a lot from the kingdom on the Odyssey and fly in the air
Poir renren cm arm ifi Feeling King efo
dose
I will choose the place I want to go with this globe and
fly.
Vercation Gua brother Charu Dard wi-fi tree In
that sense, here  Mario 64's day situation
and super Mario Sunshine's Dolpic Town is a world without a Chongqing point
to do Herb Wow
web for example Peace Power swing me
effective Odyssey Finale Pose emf Existence
That round is after Odyssey  I'm chasing Cooper over the end of the earth, but I'm
chasing after
Mario's Restoration Version Ranbu is on the top.
You need
to play not to do
d the pound 21 Ping Day Jets are you the power
borse There are a lot of music hidden in that country so please look for it all over.
Painu Audio haptic Scroll Weddy Story
Yes Then actually cooking goo do
[applause]
uso r Joy com Ease type game ender ender
step iges this game 4 f 54
tb er 4 no Petit Gua this
nice nice design 4
t so much tx 4  se 2 wb It's
when I wasn't liquor
gop n one to
do Since there is a wonderful food culture
, I thought that Europe would be the best fit to create a kingdom with the image of cooking
refer to do Fiber
That country is unique in life in Rio.  It's an art
ios Previously, in the order of the first love
of Gushi Kenyo, I'm welcoming you to the story
.  I
have a big pot for voodoo, but there
are even bigger birds in the sky.
Berger carendar Arles pou dou do  u
I'm curious about the inside of the label re only i find The contents of the toe loop and the pulley
Akora are the contents
of this pre-special dish called elbow.
Middle fan year-round
hard worker is aiming for a dance creation cafe The 4 c 2 The
site is 0
Anan
pou dou dou
Hi The song is subordinate to that play It is a hat shop with a main store It is a
hat shop
sponsored and died without a surface  Taste Yes course People know the dough
You can use that coin or the purple local coins in each country to make a cup
.
See Kimi by Swing Yushinbiya is a performance today.
The selection of people is from Koenji in the Tarbuwi tree.
Fang 21 cases.
There are some that are not available, so
please stop by if you see the shop roo Sanma 10 Ribo
Nwanchen Cab learn to Akira Sudo ecig Pastish 4 s
LCD
shobe snow is a housewife's school.
Please try to make it. In other
words, the employee snow chassis pointing face is cp battery clock Naha buchin
. I think it was gravity.
Gar
Come on, sting star bodies recipe on pc
.  I can see it, but be careful of the very hot lava. I
want me to do with
wow andere vocu half by Carp
Christiane surly cloned.
Please try throwing cb sos words of
hair
I was
able to capture the pierced pierced 4th day.
m free
I'm glad I didn't understand them-
please shake a little joy money You can move faster
Let's go the most shy king Joe nicu  That barren point is
actually the first time in the Mario series that the cherry blossoms are so freely directed to 8
can you do cab car free
power Oh Hammer Bros It
's a bar for the beginning of Derby It's not a heart version Macross Zero
hamburger  You can open it
sender
Creampan Well, if human beings are under the title of the key, this yellow one is the cheese rock
.
It's a
challenge to break a certain cheese, so if you don't have a don't cleaver, it won't be destroyed
.  It's
now possible to get a hyper too.
Sweets Power Moon Hole and taste hunting travel Like
this, there are other cups here in this kelp, so
please look for various things.
Pou dou dou That offer is big on the mountain.  The bird was sitting nicely, did you
see the game?
Security-dependent render char kono me to do
Web enjoy Penn Air Mario Extension 15:00
It was nice to be able to introduce the country of cooking from that
read happy to doing to
After that child's presentation, this presentation etc. will give you a little more detailed presentation about the Kingdom of Light.
There is, so please enjoy that one too hearn di
abeno degree is 1 teen fashion
winter winter mog About one to do
Then, there is a little more until the release on October 27, so please booby re
not to do
[Music]
Type 3  Pick Round Poster Messer Koi Zoom Good
baby Rippe's Otsu Seibu Cup Only
Nakasu per 00 b Light Bulb Bab Archer x cuba Machigou Po Amamiya Cute explanation is
Life Star dna Study Group Machihigashi 2 cases
see  you
[clapping]
[music]
iron ball newcomer
tun
me
[music]
[clapping]
whoo whoo